a coronavirus tracking site says New
York New Jersey and Connecticut are the
only states that meet Whitehouse
reopening guidelines as the fourth of
July holiday approaches outdoor water
parks playgrounds amusement parks and
some casinos will open in New Jersey
today the state has delayed plans for
indoor restaurant dining New Jersey's
governor Phil Murphy joins us now
governor good morning thanks for being
with us as we head into this holiday
weekend what concerns you the most
Anthony good to be with you this virus
by all measures is a lot more lethal
inside than outside which is why we have
delayed indoor dining not a decision
that brought us any joy but we have gone
through hell we've lost over 13 thousand
lives confirmed probably another couple
of thousands in addition to that
suspected from covin 19 loss so we're
tracking rate of transmission spot
positivity rates new hospitalizations
I'm not I'm not suggesting we can let
our hair down outside but so far at
least evidence from parks being opened
beaches being open peaceful protests the
the big concern remains indoors and
we'll be watching that like a hawk so so
many states have struggled with social
distancing at beaches do you plan to
enforce social distancing on all of your
coastline in which you have a lot yeah
we do we've got one of the great
American treasures of the Jersey Shore
we've worked very well I have to give a
big shout out across the aisle by the
way both sides of the aisle with the
Shore counties and Shore municipalities
in their mayors we've given the broad
guidelines and social distancing is at
the top of the list and the folks
locally have executed those guidelines
and based on all of our evidence over
the past month or so since Memorial Day
the the the enforcement has been good
and again outside is a lot lot more
degrees of freedom than inside when you
look at the numbers around the rest of
the country now governor how does that
factor into your decision making at this
point things are going well for New
Jersey New Jersey now but there's
there's so much out there that could
come this way
amen I mean first of all we pray for
folks
the other states that are going through
what we have gone through and we wish
them nothing but a speedy resolution to
this awful pandemic the big lesson for
me is the endorsed restaurants and bars
inside this virus is a lot more lethal
that's that's informed in large part our
decision to hold off on indoor dining
also with New York Governor Andrew Cuomo
and Ned Lamont Connecticut we have put
out a travel advisory asking folks to do
a 14-day self quarantine get tested if
you've been in a hot spot certainly the
other areas of the country have informed
that decision as well we want to do
everything we can we've lived through
hell we don't want to have to live
through this again if we could possibly
avoid it president from governor
President Trump said yesterday we're
going to be very good with the
coronavirus I think at some point that's
going to sort of just disappear what's
your reaction to that well I hope he's
right
I hope he's right please God but in the
meantime the word we use when we closed
our state was aggressive the word we're
gonna use as we reopen it step by step
is cautious and if anything we're gonna
err on the side we err to the side of
aggressive closing we're gonna err on
the side of caution opening and
hopefully God willing across the country
we could drive this thing into the
ground are you satisfied with the
federal leadership on the combating the
corona virus and you think the president
has handled this right listen I'll I'll
put words and observations aside which
we would clearly have a different
opinion on we have been able to find
common ground when it was when the heat
was highest in New Jersey when we needed
ventilators bed capacity PPE we found
common ground and I
I will say again I'm grateful for that
going forward I just hope that things
like social distancing wearing face
coverings washing your hands with soap
and water staying away from anybody if
you're not feeling well
get tested I hope all those things we
continue to drive into people's
consciousness not just at the state
level but at the national level governor
there's a lot of discussion about
mandating masks in public even even a
federal mandate would you support that
yeah we're big masks believers we we
mandate it right now endorsed anywhere
in the state it's strongly recommended
outdoors for the reasons I went through
earlier the virus is a lot more lethal
inside we're big believers in masks
social distancing plus face coverings
plus washing your hands with soap and
water and said there you think there
should be a federal I would support that
that's above my pay grade but we
certainly we certainly have it in New
Jersey but I think that's a smart move
all right Governor Phil Murphy thank you
so much for being with us
good luck this 4th of July